sure your mobile phone will give you the
time but not nearly as conveniently or
fashionably as a wristwatch does watches
come in a variety of materials often
combined with stainless steel but one of
the more creative pairings is stainless
steel with wood
this company makes wrist watches which
feature exotic hardwood accents
this particular model is a limited
edition series designed for New York
Yankees Baseball fans
blue painted Maple comes from wooden
seats salvaged from the original Yankee
Stadium which opened in 1923
at the watch Factory a worker first cuts
a strip of wood just over a third of an
inch thick then cuts it into blocks
measuring around three-fourths of an
inch by a third of an inch each
manufacturers will ultimately use these
blocks to make the wood inlays in the
lengths of the watch bracelet the worker
then Cuts another strip through a piece
of wood this one nearly a quarter of an
inch thick the worker then Cuts this
strip into nearly two by two inch
squares each one will become a ring
called a bezel that goes around the
watch dial
another worker mounts one square at a
time on a lathe and bores a hole through
the middle
you mount several board squares onto a
steel mandrel that attaches to the lathe
along with a bezel template
as the lathe turns a steel roughing
gouge rounds the squares to the diameter
of the template
she takes one bezel at a time and cuts
it to the required thickness about a
tenth of an inch
she then shaves wood from the underside
so as not to remove the historic blue
paint on top
[Music]
to make the watch case which houses the
dial and movement the manufacturers cut
a blank piece of extruded stainless
steel
then place it in a computer-guided
machine
under a continuous shower of lubricant
The Machine's 12 different tools take
turns shaping the piece into a watch
case
the first tools bore a hole in the
middle for the movement
and carve a Groove around the hole for
the wood bezel
the next tools cut the outside profile
of the case and the lugs for attaching
the watch band
then the final tool drills holes in the
lugs for the spring-loaded pins that
attach the watch band to the case
[Music]
another computer guided machine makes
the watch band and links out of a bar of
stainless steel
this machine reduces the bar in width
carves out the links and bores holes for
the connecting pins
a process called ion plating puts a
black finish on all the stainless steel
parts
then a worker assembles two bands and
connects one to the watch clasp
next he attaches the watch case window
it's made of sapphire glass a crystal
that's exceptionally durable
he inserts the self-winding movement and
dial the dial is a sheet of brass with
cut out numbers and indices over a base
coated in luminescent paint the watch
glows in the dark
secures the movement to the case with
the retaining ring then inserts the
crown which sets the Dial's hands
the worker screws on the stainless steel
case back the watches window of sapphire
glass allows you to see the working
movement inside
the case back is engraved with the name
of the limited edition collection and
this watch's number in the series
he attaches the watch band to the case
with spring pins
with the watch now fully assembled it's
time to inlay the Yankee Stadium wooden
chair accents
[Music]
a worker applies epoxy glue to the
rectangular recess in each link
then he places a wooden link piece in
each recess
[Music]
he follows the same process for the
dials wooden bezel
worker sets the watch aside for 24 hours
to let the adhesive set
[Music]
then the worker Buffs the entire surface
on a cloth polishing wheel
process removes the fingerprints and
dust and Smooths those historic wood
accents the watch automatically winds
with wrist movement to reliably tell the
time while nostalgically going back in
time
before the invention of electricity
criminal Acts were hidden by Darkness
police officers carried special lanterns
as they pursued suspects today Craftsmen
replicate these lanterns for the movie
and television Industries these props
are authentically replicated pieces of
police history
with a thick Bullseye lens to magnify
the light from the flame the 19th
century police Lantern helped find bad
guys on shadowy streets
locate a vintage police Lantern the
Craftsman starts with a piece of Steel
using a scribe he traces around a
pattern to transfer the outline to the
blank he marks notches for hinges and
for the latch and etches the shape of
the lens hole in the center
he draws two diagonal lines in the lens
hole area
the point where the lines intersect
determines the exact center
punches a divot into the steel at this
Cross Point
he scribes lines along the edges for
bending into a reinforced border later
on
he cuts out the hinge and latch notches
following the transferred pattern lines
he aligns the center divot with a punch
and then activates the punch to cut out
the hole for the lantern lens
the Craftsman now bends wire to match
the profile of the lantern door
[Music]
he aligns the wire with the scribed
lines on the edge of the door
and folds the metal over it
bending the door to the correct
curvature completes the part
following another pattern the Craftsman
marks the location for vent holes in the
blank that will become the Lantern's
main structure
out the vent holes where he's made the
marks using a hand operated punch
[Music]
he then rolls the blank into a cylinder
it takes a couple of passes to achieve
the correct curvature
moving on to the Lantern's lens holder
the Craftsman crimps a bead around one
end this bead helps to retain the
bullseye lens in the holder
returning to the lantern body he hammers
the top Rim around the cap
you preps the surface for soldering with
a chemical cleaning agent known as flux
he then solders the joint to secure the
top to the lantern
he also solders a raised panel to the
back this substantial panel serves as
support for handles
[Music]
he then cleans the solder joints with
acetone
next he wraps metal hinges around the
wire that runs through the notches in
the door
crimps the hinges together at the ends
and positions the door on the lantern
body he adjusts the hinges so the ends
sit level on the lantern
[Music]
solders the hinges to the steel
structure
the Craftsman inserts the bullseye lens
assembly into the hole in the center of
the lantern door and he solders the
joint
he pins and solders the two tiers of a
copper chimney he places the chimney
over the hole in the top of the Lantern
and Tucks more pins into holes in the
chimney
the Craftsman installs a decorative part
in the top one that won't obstruct the
chimney hole
he assembles the handles to the raised
panel at the back of the lantern
once the soldered seam hardens he files
it down
the Craftsman tests the latch on the
door and confirms that it operates
perfectly
after taping up the lens and handles he
spray paints the Lantern Black
[Music]